[Music]
one of the most remarkable things that
makes chicago so unique it's a city full
of beautiful draw bridges have you
noticed the draw bridges have you taken
some time to look at the draw bridges in
fact
right near our theater is the world
famous state street bridge check it out
there it is
gorgeous
now this one thing i noticed is that
when they raise the drawbridge up
it almost looks like a ramp
a ramp that when you think about it just
a little bit
is perfect for jumping insane chicago
related things off of
so with the permission of the chicago
transit authority chicago police
department chicago marine police chicago
fire department and a lot of people who
just seem to like to watch stuff jump
and crash
we are doing just that
every night
every night this week we'll be launching
things over the state street drawbridge
why
why are we doing this to prove that
america is still the greatest nation on
earth
usa
yes now tonight
tonight we're gonna find out
all this power wasted tonight
i've got to start doing something here
yeah yeah
tonight we're going to find out if a
10-foot bratwurst can make this jump
let's go there now
there it is a giant brat
you can buy one on any street corner in
this city
we're going to see if it can make
this jump it's an 80 foot wide jump
across
state street droppage they're getting
ready they're opening the bridge even
further
police and fire department have the area
sealed off
the anticipation
in chicago and throughout the world is
huge right now
[Music]
this has never been attempted before and
will never be attempted again
because there's really no good reason to
do it
we are ready
this is exciting
ah
[Applause]
what an incredible moment
what an incredible moment for the city
of chicago let's see the replay of that
exciting bratwurst making a jump
there it goes
that's the most beautiful thing i think
i've ever seen
[Applause]